mr. caribou hides gonna make a nice
blanket you don't just rip a caribou
hide off of the caribou and start
sleeping on it's got to be cleaned up
there's still fat on here there these
warr will fly maggots that I'm cleaning
off warm flies lay eggs on caribou and
their fur and summertime the eggs hatch
little maggots boar under the skin down
on the legs usually and then they
migrate up to the back kind of a pain
because they degrade the hide some
people find it kind of tedious but have
to work taking all that stuff off you
want to hide the last you don't want any
fat or junk that's gonna be rancid on it
without cutting holes through the heart
that's the big thing
it's a very delicate operation the goal
is to get the hide
flexible soft after it dries mostly it's
by scraping sometimes chewing on it
because what you'll see is you'll
actually see it turning the leather like
right here if you just chew it a little
bit you know the whole days people use
to hide all the time saliva actually
helps it a lot of people don't get to do
stuff like this anymore
everybody used to do this everybody used
to work on hides that was just normal
way of life it's a special feeling when
you've got your food and you're betting
on a mountain that you can see right out
the window while you're in your cabin
that's what subsistence living is it's
just nice just like doing the dishes
it's like chopping firewood working on a
hide you see the results right in front
of your eyes look at that isn't that
beautiful
that's gonna make a beautiful blanket I
like it